of all the tools an actor has in
creating the perfect look for a part
none is more important than the skillful
use of makeup
well said Steve
makeup artists are The Magicians
of the movie industry
transforming actors and actresses into
gods and goddesses of perfect appearance
through techniques handed down by the
master practitioners of their craft for
over five thousand years
the makeup artist commitment to
Excellence is all consuming
and we would not be who we are without
them
by the way will you look great thank you
you look great too
man you smell really good too
can I ask what you're wearing it's
called pineapple Bliss
are you all right that's my eyelashes
the nominees for achievement in makeup
are